[Musique]
bonjour imal aujourd'hui Miss aazot
comment furer un
[Musique]
massif l'idée c'est de pas partir tête
baissée c'est de préparer sa zone
c'est-à-dire déjà avoir une délimitation
du massif déjà ici on a utilisé de la
roche
volcanique donc ensuite j'ai apporté de
la terre végétale c'està dire de la
terre amendée et donc pour ces plantes
là ça ça ça plus facile pour se
développer donc ici avant de planter
j'ai mesuré la surface donc en fonction
de cette surface là je vais acheter les
plantes et calculer combien le nombre de
plantes pour cette surface donc ici il y
a à peu près 2,5 m² donc je vais à peu
près mettre de 50 à 60 plantes sur cette
surface là d'accord donc après ça en
fonction de soi he ici donc c'est du Z
donc il y a deux modèles il y a le
double il y a le simple donc c'est une
plante qui est qui est quand même assez
résistante et la floraison est quand
même assez jolie quand même c'est une
plante qui m pas trop trop d'entretien
et surtout c'est une plante plein
[Musique]
soleil donc je vais commencer ici
he
[Musique]
donc une petite
technique ici en dessous du pot à un
moment donné du développement ça va
créer un
chignon si on voit que le chon est trop
important donc on peut ici par exemple
casser comme ça casser la mote et les
racines vont pouvoir repartir et la va
pouvoir se développer un peu plus
rapidement donc ici on va planter tous
les 20 cm à peu
près moi j'ai une technique ça s'appelle
le bonnage j'utilise l'index et le pouce
afin d'appuyer la plante et le mettre
bien en
contact avec le sol pour plus qu'il y a
de l'air donc les racines vont être bien
en contact du sol pour son développement
c'est beaucoup mieux ici comme vous
voyez
j'ai j'ai mis la plante juste à la
surface passe du collé ici donc trop
trop au fond ni trop en haut c'est c'est
pas bon pour la
plante disposer qu on a une grande
surface mais la petite
surface on peut prendre son temps le
faire à V d'il quoi donc moi je fais
comme ça parce que je m'y connais donc
pour les gens qui veulent disposer
peuvent disposer aussi voilà ici ça
techque du quin c'est deux plantes
devant et une plante au milieu ça sera
beaucoup plus que plter en
[Musique]
ligne ben ici la rion n appelle ça grat
pays hein donc il a des gens appellent B
vieux m longtemp il appelle ça F Gog
donc ben c'est un outil pour pouvoir
planter je pense que c'est le c'est le
meilleur outil
que que ici n nous a pour moi par
rapport les les outils St plant tout çaa
moi il prof fait travailler ensemble la
grat pays quoi
entre le latanier et les il n'y aura pas
de concurrence le latanier va pas
prendre toute l'énergie donc si si on
fait un bon arrosage sur toute la
surface ben tout le monde sera
[Musique]
content
conseil pratique donc ici en pépinière
quand on achète des plantes ils sont pas
tous mouiller en fait donc voyez ici là
la mote elle est elle est carrément
sèche donc l'astuce c'est de prendre la
mote et de tremper dans un sa d'eau pour
pouvoir replanter dans le massif donc
après l'arrosage il ma pas beaucoup
d'eau en
[Musique]
fait
B au
final on a un aspect visuel directement
quoi donc on a bien choisi les plantes
au bon moment donc les plantes étaient
juste en bouton pour la floraison donc
d'ici une semaine toutes les fleurs vont
sortir et ça sera beaucoup plus joli ben
là on va arroser avec une pluie fine
c'estàdire on va utiliser un pistolet
donc si on utilise le jet d'eau ça va
abîmer les plantes là il change
d'environnement il sort de la pépine il
va directement en terre donc bien
surveiller l'arrosage et surtout arroser
plutôt le matin donc il faut pas la
stresser faut faut bien la
[Musique]
surveiller